foreign
let's go to Angela in Dayton Ohio what's
up Angela
hey what's bacon nothing
um my hips were after those Tunes but
then they they've slowed down what's up
and these Hips Don't Lie by the way
Angela what's up
they never do I never do
um I'm I'm in a situation with my family
where they have an expectation that
um I need to help pay for
bills from my parents
and um I am not in a financial situation
where I can help with things like that
the way my brother can okay
and um
they when when they don't get the answer
that they want
um they use a lot of uh bullying tactics
on me
why do you let them do that
good question
um I I took a break for my family about
15 20 minutes 20-year breaks from them
and it was the most piece I had in my
life and the highest success I've had in
my life
why'd you come back into this mess
yeah so
um my grandfather was on his deathbed
and
um my dad was having a lot of health
issues
and they were they were kind of giving
off of five like they're they've had a
change of heart
and
um things were better for uh you know
like six months I always laid right back
down crap Mountain all over again
so what has kept you from going back to
the thing that kept you safe and sane
the last time
I think
um back then I had my son and all this
was happening in front of my son and for
some reason
I've been similar to identify it because
I don't have a child reacting to the
things that they are saying to me
can I give you another alternative
yes please you care about your child's
wellness and
um safety more than yours
why is that
why aren't you worthy of of being well
I don't know
I think just because I grew up with it
that there you go
yeah and the system pulls us back in
like a vacuum cleaner and then we find
ourselves cycled out and we can breathe
again and we create our own world and
then somebody gets sick and we head back
in
um you may be like me I I remember
um at one of my jobs I mean I was
responsible for tens and tens and tens
and tens of millions of dollars an
expense in Revenue accounts hundreds of
people reported up through me it was a
big job
and then I would go home for the
holidays
and I instantly was middle child again
and I was about 14.
it's just instant you know what I mean
it just happens instantly yeah
I can relate to that because I'll go out
into the world and be a happy
functioning person at my job and around
my friends and then once I get around my
family I turn into
um and make your own child that's been
verbally attacked and kicked around
that's right all over again
and when you show up their bodies
suddenly have an outlet that they don't
normally have which is to go back to the
way things were
and so
um
the hard part is at some point you
either have to say I'm going to give up
the fantasy that this all works out in
the end because it doesn't
I don't say it doesn't it probably does
not
I think that's where I'm at right now
and if you're if you're there there's
just gonna be some deep grief
you're gonna have to spend some time
just being really sad
and being angry
because mom and dads aren't supposed to
treat you like that brothers and sisters
aren't supposed to treat you like that
right and if we're honest you've
probably contributed some and they would
be like well if she had just got her
crap together then all it just turns
into this weird dance
it's a sick dance
and when you're dancing with somebody
and they're leading you too aggressively
or they keep stepping on your toes you
can try to coach them while the music's
playing sometimes that works
well
um I was born with autoimmune disorders
and um
muscular issues that um
has I just I was just always treated
like a burden of the family in place I
was I don't think I was ever going to be
in a position
um with my family to have the same value
that my brother does okay
then at some point you've got to make a
decision am I going to be in this or I'm
going to be out of this
and you might say I can't contribute all
the money you are expecting that you're
billing me for basically
um but I do want to honor my parents and
so I can contribute this
and I will con continue to contribute
this in this way
and I I tried that well I mean it's it's
not a matter of try he doesn't get a
vote
right you didn't get a vote and so if he
won't take this or I demand this or I
demand that ah whatever
like I'm not gonna take your call how
about that
right and that's that's actually what I
did good good for you for protecting
yourself here's the thing they don't
doesn't sound like they have like
usually this gets messy when there's a
huge inheritance or something and
somebody's trying to preserve they
they're going to put up with 10 years of
being bullied and kicked around by an
idiot brother or sister
in order to be a part of the inheritance
it doesn't sound like you have anything
to worry about there
no yeah
so at some point you write the letter
that you're probably not going to send
that it is I'm sorry for the for the
whole course of my life you'll have I've
been a burden to you I'm not a burden to
me and I'm not a burden to those that
love and care about me
right and so I'm out
I wish you all the best
and you will probably
your guts will feel like they fall out
yeah
because the reality of that hitting is
gonna
it's gonna be like a ton of bricks
Fair
yeah I
I tried
um holding strong for three years in
this situation and it's
um it just feels like
Michelle love who I used to be when I'm
around them
yeah the world needs Angela to step up
and be fully Angela
will you commit to doing that
absolutely okay
and I don't say that lightly because I
know what that cost you
right it's going to cost you holidays by
yourself
it's going to cost you
um
updates it's gonna cost you all kinds of
stuff
okay it might give you back your soul
right
but I have two granddaughters I feel
like my energy would be better spent
um redirecting more of it towards them
the van
um by suddenly and my parents and
I think you're on to something and and
I'll say it this way we often
um
we often spend so much energy going back
and trying to edit things that have
happened in our lives if you think of
that like a sentence we try to go back
and edit it edit those sentences as
though we can change them
and we can't
only thing we can do with that PIN and
that paper is to write something new
and if you think about it that way
you've tried for years
to
convince your parents to act your way to
behave your way to lean into these ways
so that your parents won't see you as a
burden and they have chosen not to
you've tried hard to lean in and to do
whatever your brother's asking you to do
and he continues to up the Annie on you
he sends you a bill every month for what
you owe or with because he decided to
care and then he decided the payments
and that's just you going back and
trying to edit and trying to edit and
try to edit at some point you can look
at that sentence and say that sentence
has been written with a period at the
end of it
and you look at those beautiful
granddaughters
and you think to yourself
I can be a part of writing something new
I can teach them that they are never
going to be a burden
they're always going to be loved no
matter what knucklehead nonsense they
get involved in they're always going to
have a grandma to come home to for as
long as I'm around
and now we're writing something
completely new and right now the world
doesn't need any more editing of the
past we need people to sit down come
together and write new things into the
future
and again it's gonna hurt
it's gonna be a season of grief and a
season of sadness because the fantasy is
going to finally turn into the vapor
that it always was
but then you'll be free to look at those
two little girls and say I'm all in
let's try something new
thank you for your heart Angela